what's going on guys this is Rob and I'm
like 99 sure that Avengers King Dynasty
is basically going to be Avengers
forever by a different name so we're
going to cover that story right it might
also have a little dash of Exiles world
tour right just a little pinch thrown in
there for seasoning right just for
flavor but still uh we're gonna cover
Avengers forever this is the original
from 1998 yes Marvel's doing one from
2022. it's okay so here's the thing uh
this story basically picks up with a
couple things that we need to explain
the first is the Supreme intelligence
and the second is Rick Jones so the idea
behind Rick Jones and really seemingly
the whole reason why this story is
happening actually takes place in the
Prelude to the beginning of Avengers
forever which is basically a guy by the
name of Jones Ricard who literally just
launches an invasion against another
world freezes everybody in time and then
sends his forces which are kind of
modeled after the Avengers to slaughter
everybody so he literally kills
everybody while they're frozen in time
and they can't move and he does it
because they had some kind of a
rebellion there the way he's able to do
this is by utilizing something called
the Destiny force and we'll talk about
that here in a second but focusing on
the Supreme intelligence literally when
Kurt Busick started riding the Avengers
in like issue number seven there was a
group called The Lunatic Legion which
were just these crazy Cree members who
were residing on Earth for a while they
ended up grabbing the Supreme
intelligence who was at the center of
the earth and then brought him to the
blue area of the Moon where there's
oxygen and then they intended to like
rebuild or bring back the the cree
Empire by turning humans in decree was
it a good story no not really but that's
why the Supreme intelligence is here on
the blue area of the Moon the reason why
that matters is because the Avengers
bring Rick Jones to the Supreme
intelligence to see if those Supreme
intelligence can't figure out what's
going on with Rick Jones the reason for
this goes all the way back to the 1970s
with a story that Marvel wrote called
the crease scroll work and this is
exactly what it sounds like a war
between the cree and the Scrolls the way
the conflict came to an end is that the
Supreme intelligence woke up the powers
woke up the destiny Force inside of Rick
Jones which allowed Rex Jones to
basically end the conflict and then
those Powers were taken away by the
Supreme intelligence again but the war
ultimately ended the destiny Force
itself is like this ridiculously
enigmatic thing in Marvel Comics that's
really more of a plot device than
anything else the way it played out with
Rick Jones is that back in the day in
Marvel Comics the idea was that Rick
Jones was very similar to Bruce Banner
and the Incredible Hulk and the sense
that Rick Jones was fused with Captain
Marvel of the creep so when Marvel
wasn't running around and doing his
thing he was Rick Jones Rick Jones would
turn into Marvel and then he would be a
superhero literally he would slap his
Mega bands together and like that's how
that would work right like Wonder Woman
hitting her bracelets together but doing
more than blocking bullets so the thing
about this is that the the destiny force
of Rick Jones would intermittently pop
up here and there and the destiny Force
represents like the sum total of what
humanity is capable of right like the
greatness of what Humanity can achieve
manifests in the form of a source of
power that Rick Jones can use that's
what Jones Rick hard was using at the
beginning of the story and that's what
Rick Jones can somewhat channel of
course Jones Ricard has his own
character and we'll talk about him here
in a little while but the Avengers bring
bringing uh ring Rick Jones to the
Supreme intelligence is based on the
idea that the Supreme intelligence can
understand Rick Jones on a very
fundamental level but of course the
Supreme intelligence tells the Avengers
Leaf right like if you guys want me to
check this guy out and figure out what's
going on with him I need to do it in
privacy without you guys standing around
and watching because you're a bunch of
weirdos and so ultimately The Avengers
end up leaving here this is the arrival
of an enigmatic character that we don't
really know anything about who's just
kind of watching these things unfold and
is kind of talking to the Supreme
intelligence about how Rick Jones and
his use of the destiny force is moving
Humanity towards a precipice where they
will kind of evolve into the next state
of evolution to a higher state of being
and in turn achieve an incredible level
of power the problem here is that there
are those out there that will not want
to see this happen and this comes in the
form of immortus making his move now
let's talk about a mortise and Kane the
Conqueror and ramatut and iron lad and
all that kind of stuff let's clear all
this up so the way this worked is that
in the 30th Century you had a guy named
Nathaniel Richards Nathaniel Richards
grew bored with his timeline and decided
to go back and conquer the world by
conquering ancient Egypt he called
himself Rama tut the Fantastic Four
realized what he was doing traveled back
to the past and then defeated Rama Tut
that led to him having to go back to the
30th Century he ended up overshooting
the 30th century and landed in the 31st
century and so because human Manatee was
really primitive surrounded by advanced
technology he seized control of the
technology and then conquered the 31st
century and changed his name to Kane the
Conqueror following that he had a whole
bunch of different campaigns where he
was calling himself a scholar Centurion
and he was trying to defeat the Avengers
and different things like that and he
always lost during this time one of the
things he did is he visited his younger
self and he told him you're gonna have
to make decisions X Y and Z in order to
ensure that you become me his younger
self didn't want to do that he wanted to
become his own superhero so that led to
his younger self calling himself iron
lad now as for immortus that's explained
in this story so we'll get there soon
enough so what ends up happening here
kind of getting back to our story where
you have basically Rick Jones just kind
of sitting there in the presence of the
Supreme intelligence what ends up
happening is that immortus makes his
move by freezing time in that area like
literally freezing time all over the
place like the Earth itself everything's
frozen and then in turn sends out his
his main Force Tempest right this guy
that basically does the bidding of a
mortise what he doesn't want to get his
hands dirty Tempest shows up here and
tries to kill Rick Jones but in the
middle of that a Time bubble of forms
that actually allows Rick Jones to wake
up from being frozen in time only for
tempest to realize King the Conqueror is
there and Kane the Conqueror is the one
who created that time bubble in the
first place now the whole reason why
this happens and even the whole reason
why and mortis is doing what he's doing
is not something that we're readily
aware of at the moment instead what ends
up going on is that Tempest tries to
destroy Kang and Kang destroys Tempest
but following that immortus basically
says because Tempest was constructed out
of limbo all King has done is literally
create a portal and that basically
allows immortus Army which is called the
army of the ages to pour in to where
Kane the Conqueror is at now the army of
the ages is quite literally an army of
people from just different points in
time so this Army is composed of Samurai
and knights from the Dark Ages and
conquistadors and the whole nine yards
right even like World War one and World
War II soldiers right just people who by
whatever Manner and whatever means have
born allegiance to immortus and in turn
gone forward and done their own thing to
compare this to the MCU in the trailer
and Ant-Man quantumania at the time
we're recording this video when
basically Kang tells Scott Lang he can
give him more time and presumably Scott
Lang temporarily enters the service of
King imagine that service never ended
and that's how the army of the ages
works right literally he just ensnares
you in and keeps you there now Kang
initially wages a one-man war against
the entirety of the army of the ages but
it's a war of attrition King can't fight
them all forever and so as Rick Jones
starts to wake up King makes this last
ditch plea and says use your powers your
destiny Force whatever it is and find a
way for us to get out of this and so
Rick Jones not fully realizing what he's
doing ends up snatching Avengers out of
different points in time and the
Avengers being timed his place emerge
here right they literally arrive in this
location that's why this is important
and that's why I say that Avengers King
Dynasty is basically going to be
Avengers forever by a different name
instead of the Avengers just being
plucked Out of Time Imagine they're
plucked out of time and from other
realities and that's really how that
works so it's entirely possible that we
may actually get the Tom Cruise Superior
Iron Man but of course following this
these Avengers are familiar with each
other in the sense that they recognize
each other but they don't know each
other because they're not all from the
same point in time and so the result of
this is that they do temporarily Ally
themselves alongside Kang who literally
tells them I'm not your enemy I'm your
friend at least here in the moment we
have to find a way to destroy the army
of the ages or at the very least get
Rick Jones out of here because as long
as he's here immortus will find a way to
destroy him and it's inevitable that
immortus will kill him so the only way
to keep Rick Jones alive is to take him
outside of time to remove him from the
time stream which is the one place that
immortus simply just can't go and so
what this does is it leads to the
Avengers sort of pairing together
working together and of course defeating
the army of the ages just long enough
for immortus to realize that with the
aid of the Avengers and the fact that
it's almost like fighting an army of
kings that this is a stalemate there's
no way he can conceivably went and so
ultimately he pulls his forces out they
all withdraw and they came to conqueror
basically tells them get Rick Jones out
of here right like find a way to get him
out of here and Kane the Conqueror
ultimately ends up leaving now this
leads to the arrival of the cloaked
figure who was talking to the Supreme
intelligence that we didn't fully know
who it was and he basically Reveals His
identity as being Libra now the funny
thing about this is that Libra doesn't
matter and he never really has uh he was
a character from like back in the day in
Marvel Comics when you basically had a
group of criminals called the Zodiac for
the longest time he was filled at least
under the Roy Thomas days he was built
as a guy who could potentially be maybe
a credible threat to the Avengers kind
of that's one thing to understand about
Marvel back in the day right back in
like the 60s 70s and kind of in the 80s
before Chris Claremont took over the
took over the scene with like his X-Men
run and started introducing like
villains that were really interesting
and compelling it was by and large just
villains of the week right there were a
lot of things going on behind the scenes
and you'll find out what that is with
the comments explained podcast yes it's
on its way so the thing about this is
that that Libra was just a guy who was
there the way this is being reworked by
Kurt Busick is it's saying that Libra
despite his criminal activities was more
interested in like balance and he was
more interested in gaining knowledge and
that kind of stuff and that's why he's
here more as a guide than anything else
but again because the Avengers are kind
of boxed into a corner they don't fully
understand what's going on with this
whole situation and all they know is
that Kang who was a one-time enemy has
now turned Ally that they basically need
to to do what it is that this guy says
right because it seemingly their best
chance to make it out of all of this in
one piece and so leaving the current
timeline and stepping outside of time
they're now outside of the multi or
really out of the outside of the
universe itself but we also end up
getting this sort of breakdown of who
these different members of The Avengers
are of course you basically have two
Hank pims running around the one that
was plucked out of time is the Hank Pym
who is basically going crazy back in the
day when he was calling himself
yellowjacket but the other part here is
we're actually introduced to Songbird
now Songbird was at one point a villain
specifically she became big in the
Thunderbolts she ended up reforming and
becoming a superhero but nobody quite is
really quite sure what to make of her
but they're all kind of just plucked out
of these different moments and there's
no real Rhyme or Reason to it right it's
not like what we've seen in more recent
stories coming out of Marvel where
they're plucked from like the moment
when they're about to die right it's
just one of those things where they were
just sort of snatched up because Rick
Jones just grabbed them in a panic but
the fact that they're all here even with
Captain America himself his story is
intriguing he was plucked out at a point
when he was facing off against secret
Empire and that was a story that Marvel
wrote where Captain America actually
ended up chasing down number one who was
the leader of secret Empire that old
team actually didn't use names they used
numbers to basically differentiate a
kind of ranking system but one of the
really the leader of the secret Empire
had actually infiltrated the US
government and was working to bring the
US government down that was the
inspiration that Nick Spencer used for
the secret Empire story that he wrote 40
or 50 years later in more recent years
that focused on Captain America the
thing about this is that number one
actually ended up offing himself because
he didn't want to be taken prison which
is kind of how the members of secret
Empire function but Captain America was
painfully disillusioned with the
combination of the United States
government and just being a superhero in
general that led to him kind of stepping
away from the role of Captain America
for a time and then eventually coming
back but the overall gist of this is
that the team is hodgepodge right
they're all just kind of thrown together
in an impossible situation and no one
quiet is quite sure what's supposed to
be happening here and no one really even
understands what's going on here and so
what ends up going on here is that where
the questions asked where do they go and
what do they do because they can't just
hang out outside of Time Forever they
end up Consulting Rick Jones because
he's kind of the decision maker if for
no other reason than the fact that
they're the ones that are supposed to be
keeping him safe and so the result of
this is that Rick Jones decides that if
Kane the Conqueror was able to protect
him even if only for a moment against
the forces of immortus then what safer
place to go than to go to chronopolis
where Kane the Conqueror resides the
problem is that once they get there they
end up finding that immortus is already
attacking chronopolis because in his
mind it was the most logical place for
them to go to now some of this also has
to do with the fact that because Kane
the Conqueror sits outside of time he
sees all time simultaneously but at the
same time there are a few things going
on behind the scenes that actually keep
him from being able to know exactly
what's supposed to happen and so that's
why time traveled to a degree in this
story is kind of used as a plot device
more so than anything else but the
Avengers showing up here to chronopolis
they're able to kind of fend off some of
the forces of of immortus but the whole
idea is to actually get Rick Jones
inside of chronopolis and decaying
directly in order to figure out what to
do here the result of this is that as
they finally get inside where Kang is
Kenya is actually in the process of
effectively evacuating that his forces
here facing off against the mortis is
really more of a stopgap measure he
doesn't really have any intention of
saying like sure we can win this he
knows he can't because the forces of a
mortis are endless they're literally
plucked from the time stream and they
could stretch on forever so again a war
of attrition that's why he's doing
things like he rebuilt the Sphinx that
he used pre obviously to travel back in
time as Rama taught he's actually kind
of rebuilt that and he's moving it to a
safer location but as the Avengers
arrive here the response of Kang is this
is the last place you should have come
to right like it makes the most sense
that a mortis in an effort to keep me
from interfering would strike at the one
place that I use the most but the other
part of this is he says chronopolis is a
very particular place a very important
place when it comes to time travel and
the reason why is because traveling back
and forth through time and traveling
into the past does not allow you to
change the paths right so for example
can the Conqueror cannot travel back
into the past and destroy all the
Avengers before they ever became
Avengers right he can't do that and then
guarantee his rise to power what that
would do is it would create alternate
timelapse say that he killed five
Avengers before they ever became
Avengers now you've got five different
timelines where each one of them never
became Avengers then you've got an
infinite number of timelines on how
those things could have played out based
on those Avengers not coming into
existence right so the result of this is
he tells Janet Van Dyne the only thing
that ever happens is that we when you go
back and try to change the past you
create branching timelines and he says
that's the beauty of chronopolis
chronopolis allows me to travel back
into the past and actually modify the
past in order to affect the present day
and the future it's why a mortise is
attacking this place because at the core
of this place is literally what will
become the forever Crystal the source of
energy that powers the entirety of this
Citadel and if a mortise gets his hands
on it then a mortise can start wiping
out different universes across the
Multiverse he can just start ending
things right or just changing the past
and affecting everything else it allows
him complete and total Mastery over all
of the timelines and so while the
Avengers are able to enjoy a bit of
respite while they're here at
chronopolis meaning they can basically
experience some r r the fight's back on
again when amortis sends its forces in
yet again and so as they're facing off
against these guys that's when Kang
tells them this is a stopgap measure we
cannot hold immortus off forever
eventually he is going to overtake the
chronopolis and if Rick Jones is here
when that happens it's game over right
and so what it does is it leads to the
uh to The Avengers seizing control of
the Sphinx of Kang taking off into the
time stream while at the same time
immortus finally manages to break into
chronopolis and as he does he overpowers
Kane the Conqueror and then seizes the
heart of forever and then re-christens
it into the forever Crystal and what it
allows him to do is to literally take
the entire 31st Century where Kane the
Conqueror rules with chronopolis and
absorb everything into the forever
Crystal all beings who are present in
that location are now confined there the
issue is that immortus thought that the
Avengers and Rick Jones were still in
that vicinity once he realizes that's
not the case now it's a hunt fighting a
war on two fronts one part is immortus
going through and literally pruning the
time stream eradicating timelines that
don't need to exist the other part of it
is trying to find Rick Jones in The
Avengers because seemingly the level of
power Rick Jones has through the destiny
force is the one thing that can stand in
the way of immortus and his campaign now
it's kind of ironic about this is that
as they're able to make their escape
Libra keeps kind of telling them like we
should do this or we should do that we
should consider trying to find a way out
but the funny thing here is that Hawkeye
just kind of lashes out at Libra now of
course Libra's response here is man
you're hurting my feelings and the
response of Hawkeye has almost heard a
lot more than that if you don't get out
of here right so ultimately he chases
off their guide they're quite literally
Flying Blind throughout the entirety of
the Multiverse and so what is up
happening here is both Hank pims seize
control of the navigation systems for
the Sphinx and they pick up on the fact
that there are three chronal anomalies
taking place throughout the history of
the universe somebody's messing with
time in a significant way at three
points in time in the universe's history
and so this leads to the group splitting
into three separate groups in order to
investigate these particular points in
time now the first group to emerge is
the modern day Hank Pym along with
Captain America who show up in the 21st
century New York City right Manhattan
specifically and as they get there the
whole place is a wasteland right like
martians are laying waste to the entire
of the area they're literally killing
everybody right like everybody's more or
less been destroyed what's funny about
this is this actually was inspired by
The War of the Worlds and so as they
make their way through there Captain
America's and of course Ant-Man are
fighting against some various forces
they're able to hold their own to a
degree but when there's a spot that's
open where Captain America is almost
taken out he's actually saved by the
Avengers of this timeline which
basically turns out to be led by black
panther but the other part about this is
this black panther here is actually
t'challa it's the real t'challa who's of
course older and he's a lot more
grizzled and hardened than he used to be
but what he basically explains is that
somewhere along the line a massive
conflict took place and the marshes
started invading and like The Avengers
were basically killed so seeing Captain
America here takes him by surprise
because Steve Rogers is supposed to be
dead now Steve Rogers of course fesses
up right off the bat and says well I'm
not from this time stream home slice uh
I am from like back in the day now the
other group that comes together is
Hawkeye and the past Hank Pym along with
Songbird who end up in the old west now
the funny thing about this is Songbird
knows how this whole situation plays out
and so what you end up coming up on is
like the two gun kid and these
characters who are basically older
characters of Marvel usakai used to
publish way back in the day when like
Stan Lee was the one man show who was
basically creating everything and this
led to them basically focusing on like
Western Comics and things like that two
gun kids not really important he hasn't
been for a long time in Marvel Comics
but this is basically a point where Kang
is trying to conquer this part of
history in the 19th century songbirds is
kind of like all right look we gotta go
like we don't have time to face off
against Kang here besides I know how
this plays out some Avengers show up
here they defeat Kane the Conqueror he
goes back to his time and like the day's
safe so there really isn't anything for
us to do here so they end up basically
bailing out but when they get back to
where their time sphere is supposed to
be it's gone right somebody took it and
so the third group is genus Val also
known as the new Captain Marvel along
with Janet van Don we don't really need
to go to specifically in the genus Veil
he's kind of the roundabout son of
Marvel I want to say that he was created
right he was literally cloned from
Marvel but I'm not gonna swear to that
off the top of my head honestly I'm not
overly familiar with him because he
hasn't been relevant in Marvel Comics
for like 25 years but literally he's
just the new cosmic-powered Avenger
who's plucked out of time by Rick Jones
and was brought here right so it's not
overly important with his character the
thing about this and what's really kind
of crazy is where the story sort of goes
off the rails a little bit that Richard
Nixon is on the campaign Trail because
this is 1959 and uh Marvel realizes that
it's not actually Richard Nixon that is
a scroll pretending to be Richard Nixon
but what matters here is that where
genus Val initially goes to make a move
against basically Richard Nixon the vice
president of the United States
he goes to attack the guy knowing that
he's a scroll that Avengers end up
stepping in here now this Avengers team
they originally appeared in what if
Issue Number Nine back in March of 1978
they were actually uh an Avengers team
that was brought together by Jimmy woo
and actually served as more of like a
presidential guard initially it dealt
with a villain named Yellow Claw who
tried to kidnap president Dwight
Eisenhower and take him out of course
the Avengers basically came together and
defeated him and save the president and
following that they remained as kind of
a detail at this point in time they're
basically protecting Richard Nixon but
again they're not an overly important
team 3D man like the guy who's in the
weird looking get up he's okay right
he's he's interesting you have a few
recognizable characters here but none of
these guys are overly important right
pulling a page out of and really kind of
talking about the future of the MCU this
could be yet another Avengers team that
we've never seen before that exists out
there in the Multiverse so that's why
these kinds of things are really really
cool and they're really fascinating
because what you're dealing with here is
not only the uh the manipulation of time
but the jumping in and out of alternate
realities here now of course each one of
these groups has their own individual
stories and so focus on on this old what
if Avengers team meeting The Avengers
team that's currently trying to figure
out what's going on with these time
anomalies that the time Avengers we can
call them that in order to keep that
separation simple they basically reveal
that Richard Nixon's a scroll and that
the Avengers themselves just kind of
take the time Avengers at their work but
they also kind of say look I mean this
is sort of what's going on here or
something you have to be aware of that
the idea of this Scrolls being here is
to literally sabotage the United States
space program that's the whole point in
order to keep humans from going into
space when they did but of course once
this Revelation comes out then the
Avengers tell the time Avengers okay
we're on your side we'll stop fighting
we gotta find a way to deal with Richard
Nixon now jumping back to the Avengers
in the west what they end up finding out
is that it was actually Kane the
Conqueror who at that point in time is
trying to conquer the 19th century and
has somehow become aware of the fact
that they're there he's the one that
stole their sphere so when they get back
there like a king hologram kind of
taunts them a little bit and then tries
to collapse the cave in songbirds able
to save them but that leads to the
arrival of the gun Hawks right so you
basically have the black writer you've
got Reno Jones kid Cassidy right you
have these old western characters that
are here trying to help them out as best
they can and saying okay obviously Kane
the Conqueror is the guy who's the main
villain here let's deal with him and
then we'll find a way to get you guys
back to your normal time I mean their
old western superheroes who are running
around with with revolvers like what are
they gonna do but the thing about this
and they kicker about all this is is
that you have Hawkeye who's a massive
fan of like old westerns and he's a
massive fan of these guys right he's
like I spent my whole life reading about
you studying your history it's so
fascinating to be able to meet you you
can't imagine how impossible this is and
when kid Cassidy's like yeah man I mean
it's a cool experience Hawkeye says
especially because kid Cassidy was dead
by 1873. so that's what he realizes it's
not kid Cassidy it's somebody posing as
kid Cassidy and he tells the Avengers
like hit him right so literally it's
just like he takes out kid casting he's
like get him guys and like the Avengers
and snare these guys only for us to find
out that they're basically space
Phantoms and the space Phantoms are
forces of Immortals in the old school
Comics there was only one space Phantom
that was ever encountered as a as a kind
of servant of immortus what this shows
is he's got a whole host of them the
bigger Point here and the reason why
this matters is because it demonstrates
immortus has spies everywhere all over
the place now there's no way to know
because the space Phantoms are
shapeshifters so there's no way to know
if the person is standing next to you is
a space Phantom or if they're basically
the person they've always claimed to be
and that's the concern that they
initially have when you go back to the
to the situation with Richard Nixon that
you've got the time Avengers and you've
got the regular Avengers who are all
kind of meeting they're met with two FBI
agents out of nowhere Captain Marvel
picks up on what's going on and realizes
they're not FBI agents he attacks them
they're space Phantoms and those guys
are defeated but what's crazy is that
before they can deal with that whole
situation immortus arrives on the scene
clutching the forever Crystal and
literally starts emanating this sort of
cronal warp where he starts wiping out
everything in existence from his point
spreading in an outward Direction he
literally obliterates the entirety of
the time stream and the universe those
Avengers the time Avengers make it out
just in time the other part of this is
that the actions of immortus are also
impacting the 19th century where the
other time Avengers are out so they end
up bailing out of there as fast as they
possibly can and so at this point the
only group remaining in the timeline
that they had arrived at is Captain
America and the present-day Hank Pym and
so what they end up doing doing is
actually traveling with black panther to
the remnants of wakanda which has long
since been a destroyed State and what
what ends up happening is Black Panther
literally says because of the fact that
these Alien Invaders are so incredibly
Advanced and our ability to chase after
them following their defeat is
non-existent because our planet doesn't
have any sort of space travel technology
anymore he says we can literally grab
what's left of the vibranium in wakanda
and we can retrofit some vessels and
then basically go after the Martians
themselves the problem here is that when
they get there because of the
manipulations of immortus there's an
entire race that operates within the
Subterranean realm right under wakanda
down in the great Mound that feeds off
the vibranium there so to take what's
left of the vibranium would wipe out
that entire race and so that is a point
where now black panther at the behest of
Captain America has to make a choice
Captain America's stance is either you
can take what's left of this vibranium
and you can wipe out this entire race
and hope the ships that you retrofit
will lead to you being able to launch an
attack on the Martians and Destroy them
so they can never come back to earth or
you can leave this vibranium here you
can let this race continue on you can
hope the Martians never come back and
you can start rebuilding Earth which one
is it going to be ultimately black
panther ends up choosing to leave the
race alone to let them stay within the
Subterranean realm of wakanda feeding
off the vibranium and then to try to
rebuild the surface World hoping
everything can go back to normal the
cool thing here is that at this point in
time you haven't really seen immortus
making his move in the 21st century he
hasn't arrived here yet in order to do
anything and so what this does is it
leads to Captain America and his guys
basically heading back using their
chronal vessel to the Sphinx and then
reuniting with the rest of the Avengers
and so what ends up happening here is
with the Avengers completely reunited
but realizing that immortus is traveling
through the time stream and wiping out
entire universes the only thing that
they can do is actually head directly to
limbo and to try to fight him head-on
what's really crazy about all of this is
this is just the surface stuff right
like the whole scheme of immortus is
much much bigger than what's going on at
least what we've initially been led to
belief that what we're talking about
here is the presumed destruction and
Recreation of the entirety of the
Multiverse in Marvel Comics but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end I know this was a
chunky one and there's a lot of stuff to
take in thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later
peace